former NSA contractor Edward Snowden is
shedding new light on his decision to
reveal classified documents about the US
government's mass surveillance program
back in 2013
Snowden disclosed government programs
that collected Americans emails phone
calls and Internet activity all in the
name of national security
the US government charged Snowden under
the Espionage Act for his actions a
congressional report says his
disclosures caused tremendous damage to
national security well in his new memoir
permanent records Snowden tells his
story in detail for the first time and
speaks about his life in exile in Russia
Snowden who now identifies himself as a
privacy advocate spoke with us and an
exclusive US TV interview that we taped
earlier this morning you said in the
book that you wish you had had a
strategy in terms of a what's next plan
once you release these documents you sit
here six years later in exile in Moscow
where you've said you don't want to be
was it worth it it was I mean when we
look at these all of these complexities
and all the consequences that we have as
a result of any of the decisions as we
go through our lives I think we realized
that look we see chances opportunities
in life where we can make a decision to
try to change something and right now in
2019 it's hard to look around at the
world and think nothing needs to change
but nothing changes just if we believe
in something we have to actually be
willing to risk something we have to
actually be willing to stand for
something but you took an oath to the
Constitution Edward you took an oath not
to betray the country you know the CIA
has what you call an an orientation
indoctrination program where they have a
parade of horribles and now you're on
the list a parade of horribles your
pictures they're probably yes but that's
actually an important point is I was
required to swear an oath when I entered
onto duty in the CIA it's a very solemn
thing you're in a darkened room in front
of a flag everyone else is there but
it's important to notice that we did not
say an oath of secrecy one of the common
misconceptions in one of the early
attacks that you heard a lot in 2013 you
don't hear so much anymore is that I
violated this oath of secrecy
that does not exist there's a secrecy
agreement but there's also an oath of
service an oath of service is to support
and defend not an agency not even a
president it's to support an defend the
Constitution of the United States of
America against all enemies this direct
quote foreign and domestic and so this
begs the question what happens when our
obligations come into conflict right
when what happens when you have a
secrecy agreement but you have also
witnessed your own government your own
agency your workplace violating the
rights of Americans and people around
the world on a massive scale
this is a very personal book mr. Snowden
and I and as you pointed out growing up
in in the intelligence community and
your parents were in government it
wasn't easy for you to become personal
here but I am curious since he grew up
in a community where almost everyone was
in somehow connected to government
service many of them the FBI how did you
did you probe approached your family at
all about this how did they react to it
when you went through this process and
and how do they feel about it now and
this was actually one of the hardest
parts of coming forward was that I
couldn't talk to anybody about it
because this is the bizarre sort of
circumstance of the way our laws are
currently structured in 2013 I was a
contractor working for the NSA through a
private company I worked in an NSA
facility I had an NSA boss you know
who's working at NSA systems doing NSA
tasks but formally just on paper I work
for a private company now these
contractors weren't covered by
whistleblower protection laws if I had
tried to talk to you know a judge a
priest a congressman it would have been
the same felony if I had talked to my
family it would have been the same
felony and of course if I had talked to
a journalist they consider telling the
truth about the government breaking the
law is itself a crime and so I couldn't
tell anyone I couldn't tell the the the
love of my life
who's the central figure in the story
Lindsey Mills my longtime partner
because if I had the FBI could have
charged
her is a part of a conspiracy they could
have charged her as a kind of accessory
to the crime so long as she didn't
immediately after hearing from me you
know I'm thinking about talking to
journalists picked up the phone and said
help help somebody's going to talk to
the press and so that made it a very
isolating experience Edward your former
employer the NSA said they couldn't
comment on your book because of the
ongoing investigation but they did give
us a following statement Edward Snowden
violated his lifetime obligation to
protect classified information and
betrayed the trust of his co-workers and
the American people and would you
acknowledge that you broke the law and
that there are many people in this
country who see your actions as
traitorous well I won't take a position
on whether or not I broke the law
because that's one for lawyers but what
I will say is this you know it's not
hard to make the argument that I broke
the law and I think that's actually the
less interesting question it's funny
that whenever the government comes after
me they say you know these disclosures
cause harm but they never justify the
harm they never show evidence for even
though we're now more than six years on
it would be the easiest thing in the
world but Edward never heard that's the
question of harm I don't know that your
forgive me but how are you in a position
to judge the harm of your disclosures
isn't that something that the
intelligence community would be uniquely
situated to gauge well I would argue I
worked for the u.s. intelligence agency
for quite a long time I am the only one
who knows the actual documents that the
journalists have and the ones that they
published we all know so it's available
to all of us to assess the harms and
again if they had some classified
information if they had some classified
evidence that you know a hair on a
single person's head was harmed you know
as well as I do it would be on the front
page of the New York Times by the end of
the day because leaking is not something
that only happens the people that are
working to inform the press are doing it
it's also what the government does to
sort of backstop their positions there
are authorized leaks that happen all the
time that are not public interest
whistleblowing right but back to that
that question of you know did did I
break the law again
and what's the the question that's more
important here was the law broken or was
that the right thing to do
if you look back at the history of the
United States it doesn't take very long
for the average person to think about a
moment in which it was absolutely
illegal to do something but at the same
time it was absolutely the right thing
to do you're living in Russia and have
for some time now as you pointed out
it's it's it's not where you want to be
it's where you were forced to be have
the Russians ever asked for any
information from you well this is
actually a big scene in the book as soon
as I landed and and for the audience
that may be less familiar with the story
it was never my intention to be in
Russia I was actually transiting enroute
to Latin America the United States
government for some reason we don't know
whether it was intentionally to create
kind of a evergreen political attack
against me guilt by association of being
able to point to the Russian government
or they simply panicked when they saw
that I might be what they considered
escaping they canceled my passport and
that went when I landed I could no
longer travel so I get pulled out a
passport control and brought into a room
and yes directly the Russian
intelligence service is like you know do
you want to cooperate do you have any
information life is going to be very
hard if you have no one on your side and
I said look you know that's not how this
is going to be that's not how this is
going to work I don't have any
information you can search my bag if you
want because I destroyed my information
before I got on the plane and I think
that was a probably what they expected
because remember there's about four
thousand journalists downstairs looking
for me in this airport at the moment I'm
on every TV channel on every newspaper
and I was just trying to continue on my
journey into asylum now the the reason
that you know this actually happened
because you might be skeptical you might
go well the Russians are just gonna let
this guy go Russia has shall we say a
problematic human rights record at a
minimum that's if we're being generous
now when we look at the opportunities
that they have to do the
on the international stage it seems
pretty few and far between but here's a
circumstance where they don't have to do
anything to do the right thing all they
have to do is not hand me over but even
despite that even the fact that Russia
was probably the hardest place in the
world for the CIA to operate I didn't go
alright this is great you know let me
out of the airport I was stuck in that
Airport for 40 days monitoring your
actions today do you think that there
are gathering intelligence on you
because the optics as we said here in
America looking at you in Russia you
know the optics are not good no you're
absolutely right again and I'm on the
same side on decision you know one of
the one of the big topics in Europe
right now is should Germany and grant
France invite me in to get asylum that's
how they're handling the response to
this this new book but when you look at
that kind of thing yeah of course it's
problematic and of course I would like
to return to the United States that is
the ultimate goal but if I'm gonna spend
the rest of my life in prison the one
bottom line demand that we all have to
agree to is that at least I get a fair
trial and that is the one thing the
government has refused to guarantee
because they won't provide access to
what's called a Public Interest defense
and all due respect criminals and
alleged criminals don't customarily get
to decide the terms of their trial they
broke the law and they face the
consequences what makes you different
well I'm not different
again I'm not asking for a parade I'm
not asking for a pardon I'm not asking
for a pass what I'm asking for is a fair
trial and this is the bottom line that
any American should require right we
don't want people thrown in prison
without the jury being able to decide
whether what they did was right or wrong
the government wants to have a different
kind of trial they want to use special
procedures they want to be able to close
the courtroom they want the public not
to be able to go know what's going on
and essentially the most important fact
to the government and this is the thing
we have a point of contention
is that they do not want the jury to be
able to consider the motivations why I
did what I did was it better for the
United States did it benefit us or did
it cause harm they don't want the jury
to consider that at all they want the
jury strictly to consider whether these
actions were lawful or unlawful not
whether they were right or wrong and I'm
sorry but that defeats the purpose of a
jury trial you were able to steal 1.5
million documents which is an astounding
number do you think that could be done
today first off that's not correct
that's the government's number and all
of the journalists have been handling
this archive for years I have said
that's not accurate you're asking a
privacy advocate for private information
of course that's not going to go very
well but good but good try what I will
say is this I gathered a lot of
information about what I believed was
evidence of criminal activity on the
part of the United States government
unconstitutional programs and simply
things that were problematic that were
ethically questionable and I provided
these to journalists and this is this is
critical here the number of documents
that I published is zero so when the
government says I caused harm what do
they mean by that what they mean is the
press having access to things the
government didn't want the public to
know decided and made an institutional
judgment and these are some of the most
trusted institutions and journalism like
the Washington Post and these guys said
the public has a right to know this and
I have required them as a condition
these journalists as a condition of
access to this archiving of material to
make an agreement that they would
publish no story simply because it was
interesting no story simply because it
was newsworthy they could only publish
stories that they said were in the
public interest to know and is an
extraordinary measure on top of this to
sort of reconstruct the system of checks
and balances that had failed internally
in government between the executive and
legislative and judicial branches the
journalists would then in advance of
publication warn the government about
the story they were about to break
would give the government an adversarial
stage in the process and argue against
this story go you guys don't understand
this or Snowden's a liar these documents
are fake or even if it's absolutely
right somebody will be hurt as a result
of this and so they could always make
these arguments in the publication
processes and as far as I understand
that this process was followed
throughout all the publication's and
that is why I am so confident now in
2019
that despite the evergreen sort of
allegations of government whenever any
whistleblower comes up they say causes
harm it causes harm and causes harm we
have never seen any evidence of that and
just one last point on that because I
think it is especially critical just
remember the history of this we have
always seen that in this country when
the country when the country not the
country when the government is
embarrassed for being caught breaking
the law they say the people who revealed
that law breaking have caused serious
harm in national security this was the
case of Daniel Ellsberg way back and the
Vietnam War with the Pentagon Papers
which was the classified history of the
government's war in Vietnam
now Ellsberg yes and they said we're not
going back it's just it's just a central
principle here what harms the country is
it a war built on lies or is the
revelation of those lies is it the
construction of a system of mass
surveillance that violates our rights or
is it the revelation of that by the
newspapers that we trust if we can't
trust newspapers if we can't agree on
the basic facts and then have a
discussion about whether this was right
or wrong
not simply lawful or unlawful we're
losing our position as a democracy and
as a government that is controlled by
the people rather than people that are
controlled by the government all right
Edward Snowden it's interesting you say
the newspapers released it but you gave
the information to the newspapers to
release minor detail there we thank you
very much for taking us on we thank you
for taking the time I do so much the
story's not over thank you